the jurogan experience tell me what you
got there
and you know talking about bear grease
and trying to connect it to a podcast
i mean at some point i'll have to
explain the metaphor
of bear grease what's explaining now
well
so bear greece at one time was this
highly valued commodity
i mean used as a a unit of currency
on the american frontier and and bear
bear grease bare oil would be the
rendered fat of a bear that would turn
into
liquid like this right here this is this
is for you
thank you have you ever have you ever
had i mean i know you've bear hunted but
yeah you had bear grease before
no i've only i've eaten bear i've never
rendered bare fat or cooked anything in
bare fat
i've only just taken the meat and cooked
it yeah usually
slow cooking so what you would do with
that is you would cook with it
you would fry with it you could make
pastries with it
you can use it to condition leather you
can supposed to be able to condition
pastries
yep and so there was a time when
bear greece bear lard was super valuable
on the frontier
before refrigeration because bear fat
stayed
didn't go rancid as quickly as pork lard
so like on it
you would have pork and bear would be
essentially the places where you would
get it
this lasted longer that'll last on the
shelf at your house
unrefrigerated for over a year why is it
why does it last so much
just whatever the constituency of
bear lard is it just stays good for that
long
so going back to this metaphor the name
of bear grease
in our podcast we're we're exploring
things and even in the in the
in the in the you know the the tagline
of the podcast
we say that we're exploring things or
things that are forgotten
but relevant and we're searching for
insight in unlikely places
and so like this bear bear grease i
brought you some stuff that you can do
with bear grease
this is uh this is some bear fat lye
soap
if you've if you ever used animal tallow
soap
no like just for like bathing washing
your hands man
that's incredible stuff yeah it really
is 100 all natural i mean it's
it's it's a it's a ancient process of
using lye
and animal talos what is lie exactly lie
is
uh gone if you hadn't asked me it's it's
i mean it's a it's a chemical it's a
caustic chemical that you can buy just
about anywhere
but uh shoot how does that look like h2
something something that they used to
use ash
they use they they got the lie from ash
and uh
it's a metal hydroxide traditionally
obtained
by leaching wood ashes yeah or a strong
alkali which is highly soluble in water
producing caustic
naoh solutions sodium sodium hydroxide
that's what it is
so they would get it from like burning
wood yeah
so they they're the real primitive
method for making soap
from from animal tallow and you could
use you could make animal talos soap out
of
beef towel anything but bear fat lie
soap
is uh is is our specialty not it
but it um it's supposed to be real good
for your skin
it's what you know but you can sell this
no you say our special you never sell it
just give it to you
no no no this is not not for sale just
uh
but did you make this yeah yeah and so
what are the what's the ingredients so
just lie and
four four ingredients bare fat sodium
hydroxide lye
water and then just essential oils we
just smell
yeah the wood smells smells good yeah
what are the essential oils
we had a bunch of different kind of oils
that we added in like peppermint
whatever i don't know
sometimes i'm amazed at how you know
kind of like hygiene
conscious us bear hunters are like
making soap and stuff because
the other thing i brought you joe and i
know you don't you don't you don't run a
beard but uh
this is some bear grease beard oil that
i made
and so that is a combination of three
things
so it's it's cheating just a little bit
but it's it's it's
one part bare oil one part almond oil
one part jojoba oil and then essential
oils
and i mean you can drip it out put it on
your hands and
that smells good yeah interesting
and then the last one here and then i'll
start talking about my metaphor again if
you're if you want but this is a bear
grease
hand salve and so bare oil
has all kind of folklore around it and
i'm in the process of like
an anecdotal research very serious
project of
exploring all these folk tales of bear
grease and bare oil so it's healing
properties yeah yeah they
they say i mean back in the day bare oil
would have been used to relieve
arthritis pain um they say and you can
find this all over the internet
that bare oil cures baldness
which obviously is like a big piece of
folklore
right but it's still just fun but going
back to the idea that bear grease has
all these uses
is that this is thing that at one time
was the currency and if you
polled the united states 330 million
americans
and you said what is bear grease i mean
like
what percentage of people would even
know what it was
probably one percent of one percent
yeah so it's been forgotten and
so there was a time when so there's an
archaic
unit of measure of a barrel they used to
take the tanned
neck height of a deer which would have
been a part of the
the buckskin that wasn't usable the neck
hide
and they would have sewed it together
and they would have used it to have
stored
bare oil and they called it an eel
and i so they would make a container out
of it like make a container
almost an eel of bear oil and it's just
a wonder
spell it like eel well it it you know
it's been probably 10 years since i've
actually seen it written it's i think
it's
e-l-l-e like um
an eel of of bare oil would have been a
unit of measurement so like you could
have gone to the store and you're like
well i got two ills bare oil
you know i'd like some flour i'd like
some whatever and
you know it's just it's a wonder that we
don't call the u.s dollar you know an
eel
you see you know because the buck is
essentially connected to
the value of a white-tailed deerskin
that was tanned out
and ready for tanning and that became
equivalent to
a buck for one dollar for one dollar wow
and so
so again this idea that there's some
pretty amazing stuff that's forgotten
and then as hunters we're very
interested in using as much as we can
from these animals that we're taking
very interested in that and so a bear
offers a whole nother market of
commodity that
really no other big game offers in that
you know
of the big game that we hunt like like
let's say an elk
i mean like you know you're gonna you're
gonna keep the meat obviously that's
number one thing
you're gonna keep his horns but very few
people would even keep the hide of that
animal and certainly they're not
rendering down elk tallow white-tailed
deer would have the same
sequence of usable commodities man a
black bear we
have incredible meat we
i would i would venture to say that 90
percent
maybe 80 percent of black bears that are
killed in north america their hides are
tanned
they have usually especially in the fall
will have an incredible amount of fat
which can be rendered down into all
these incredible healthy
usable products and uh
and so i mean like we have we use my
point is we use more of a
of a bear than we do almost any other
big game animal that we hunt
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience